hans how's it going hey it's going good
good to hear from you how are you good
good you on the road yeah i'm on the
road again we just smoked the ball and
just hit the road and we recorded a
podcast
we found
one second
dude i'm actually using tinder evie
right now dude get on it
oh
how did i match with the
oh i shouldn't say things like that but
let's see the picture and let's decide
[Music]
what's the bucket for
trash is the other one diesel
no that's urine
hey what's up guys it's hans kim here
i'm a stand-up comedian living in a van
and this is my good old friend michael
hirsch
this is where rocky balboa uh got aids
in that movie philadelphia is that
diesel though yeah
it's my urination
i need to
dump my pee
i need
[Music]
i'm a parasite
[Music]
this is real van life it's not pretty
okay google youtube rocky movie
holy [ __ ]
80
81
82
83
do you know coach frank yes he's my
son-in-law he's your son-in-law that
sounds a little spicy what do you even
know about hockey and we're going to the
constitution we're going to pats and
gino's cheesesteaks i don't think the
constitution is in philadelphia
hi can i get a cheesesteak please 22.
22.
i only have five dollars cash 10 money
the rest
sorry i don't have enough cash
for both yeah i have 11.
50. how much was it
[Music]
[Applause]
is
[Music]
who's that one are you sure yeah no i no
no no i know it's that one because i
know the car
you [ __ ] it up again
we held up traffic significantly hey
look at all these cars
they turn off the lights the tide
i don't want them to see my face
that's a
fresh pea going right down the drain
out of my life and into the gutters
i love the smell of fresh pea in the
morning